Speaker 1: All right, Dave from Northern
California, great to hear from you. Let's
go to Amos from Kansas. Amos from Kansas City.
Welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. I'm a long time listener, a
longtime supporter of you, and I'm happy to be on
here. First time I've ever gotten on. But first, I
had a question, but I wanted to answer one of your
questions that you asked a couple of weeks ago.
But what Lauren Boebert loves to say those words,
pleading the blood of Jesus. Yeah, I was
born and raised apostolic, Pentecostal,
so I could tell you what that means.
Speaker 1: Please. What does.
Speaker 2: It mean? It's kind of a legal term, but
in the way that like Jesus died for you because.
And that blood that he spilled was a covenant
between God and man. And so when things go wrong,
we plead the blood of the covenant.
Speaker 1: And who do you
plead? Who do you plead to?
Speaker 2: God himself. God,
the Father. Because the covenant is Jesus
Christ, blood. And he's that. And yeah,
that's the best way I can explain it, but
that's how it explained to me and growing up.
Speaker 1: And what are you pleading for?
Speaker 2: And it depends on the situation,
I guess, for and Lauren Boebert situation,
it would be pleading the blood for, you know,
making Trump president or something like that.
Speaker 1: So if I understand correctly,
you would plead the blood of
Jesus to God in order to achieve
something that you want.
Speaker 2: Yes. Pretty.
Speaker 1: Got it. Okay. All right. Very good.
Speaker 2: I understand that. That that's just
my explanation for it. But anyway, my question
for you has to do with I'm a big follower of a
guy named Metta, and he did a poll and he's like
you. He gets these A-plus rated polls and stuff,
but he did it on the the religions of the
world that are best seen, most positively and
most negatively. Okay. And I wanted to know your
opinion on this, because it according to the poll,
Mormons are the most or the least positively
viewed religion. However, even though it doesn't
seem like it based upon the I don't know, the
loudness of the minorities. It. Jews are the
most positively seen, according to his polls.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So. So let's let's be clear.
The poll you're referring to is a Pew Research
Center poll. So I think it's important when we
say his poll. I follow him on on Twitter. It's a
Pew Research Center poll. So quite, quite, quite
reputable. So the this is only among Americans,
I think it's important to mention that's one
thing. This these are not global views about these
different religions. And you're absolutely right.
Among Americans, Jews followed by. Well, see, it's
kind of complicated because of how this is rank.
Jews almost perfectly followed by Catholics, then
mainline Protestants, then evangelical Christians,
then atheists, Muslims and Mormons in that
order are seen as most favorable to to sort
of like least favorable. The difficulty about
that poll is it's all kind of low numbers, like
the difference between the least favorable, which
is Mormons and Jews, which is the most favorable,
is only 20 points. It's 15 to 35. So I have a
couple different thoughts on this. Number one,
the U.S. has a different sort of perspective on
a lot of these religions than the world. So like,
I think that Mormonism might be seen differently
in other parts of the world where that, like the
population of Mormons, is very different. It's a
very interesting poll. I don't really know what
to make of it. I do think that when it comes to
Jews, some of the favorable is probably based in
anti-Semitic tropes, like people who are like, Oh
yeah, Jews control some great industries. So like,
I see them favorably in that way. But
it doesn't necessarily mean that, like,
you necessarily think Jews are good people
or whatever, you know what I'm saying?
Speaker 2: Right, Right.
Speaker 1: But it is a very interesting poll.
Yeah. I you know, the other thing about it is
the vast majority of respondents have no opinion
about most of those religions. Like 60% of the
respondents said I don't have any. I don't know
enough about Jews to say one way or the other.
Speaker 2: Well, I if it's any consolation,
I view old all Jews to be the you know,
my my mother's side of the family is a
lot of there's a lot of that is Jewish.
Okay. But anyway, thank you very much.
Speaker 1: All right. Yeah. Very interesting poll.
Thanks for bringing it up. I do appreciate that.